[Music]
three words Wow okay come one of the
words be hyphenated self-deprecating
radical caring and unexpected caring Wow
Amaya Monica is this a friend's dance
that bold outspoken and sensitive
creative honest silly energetic calming
inspirational no oh yeah what Oh God
is this what it is I'm curious to see
who my friends are oh yeah hilarious
big-hearted incredible hilarious genuine
and unpredictable funny kind singsong
that was Derek Derek sensing I wish I
believed them genuine unstoppable and
iconic unpredictable colorful and kind
maybe a ho
yes confident inspiring beautiful inside
and out Wow I would never describe
myself and that many nice words this is
the most pressure I've ever had in my
life funny smart zesty dude did Ryan say
zesty this investing cool artists
opinionated that's true
creative kind passionate oh it's nice to
know that I guess other people see you
the way you see yourself beautiful
genuine and strong
goddess angel baby darling funny
lovely and cratis that's just reminds me
of an adult all in the face it's in the
way that you treat people considerate
intelligent and sassy energetic comical
independent loud intelligent and funny
extra wow that's the most precious thing
in the world awesome leather norm funny
thing
funny hot cool dirty so I'm just a lot
of tented temperatures visionary ribbon
and maybe a bit of a diva passionate
brilliant and stubborn he is so [ __ ]
stubborn did [ __ ] Zack say that yeah
[ __ ]
can I quickly pick three words for each
of them keith is waffle pancakes chicken
Ned is married married married and then
Zack is ow my back